[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to be talking about the
power of curiosity we have Vika Victoria
joining us on the show hello hello
lovely to be here thank you so much for
coming in we practice
I love Vitas work I'm super excited to
host her for those that don't know Vitas
background she's an award-winning
storyteller speaker and relational
wealth advisor her interactive lectures
the power of curiosity cultivating
relational wealth and modern
masculinities tension plus release have
electrified audiences on global stages
for the past two years he has been
curating an underground men's dinner
salon series around the world in cities
like Berlin Tel Aviv Sydney and New York
City the basis of her upcoming book
brave new men for leaders and teams Vika
teaches relational wealth strategies and
how to speak their stories with intrigue
and impact Vika also leads men's
intensives on self awareness self love
and self expression individually and in
group settings you can check out the
links in the bio to brave new men calm
also her linkedin and her instagram
alright this is gonna be such a good
episode so palm to be Colette start
things off with one of our favorite
questions what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world mmm really good
question I am unconsciously optimistic I
think we live in one of the greatest
times that has ever existed and it's
because we're aware of it we have
technology that connects that awareness
in a not-so-silent fabric of genius and
so what I'm really excited about is the
ability for all of us to tap into our
individual genius and collective genius
to solve the greatest problems in the
world and I know you and I have been
lucky enough to talk to some of the
people that are on at the helm of the
ship doing this work so yeah I'm feeling
like we're taking responsibility in ways
we've no
ever taken responsibility before you
know things that used to be really taboo
like yoga meditation veganism are now
going totally mainstream so I think
overall as a society we're waking up and
we're understanding that we have to do
better if we want to survive and what
would you say are some of those key
principles for the creative genius to be
fully Unleashed
to feel seen and safe I think is a
really big part of it to feel that your
voice matters so there's an element of
significance not to be confused with an
egoic importance but simply
understanding that every single person
was born with a unique cross-section of
matrix of talents and the way that you
cultivate those talents and apply them
to problems in the world is the worth
that you're gonna feel yeah this is a
very powerful intro I love it let's um
let's get into the journey so born in
Ukraine and then went to New York would
spent most time in Georgia what and
somehow I ended up with brave new men to
teach us about this so this will be a
fun short form moth so I was born in the
former Soviet Union to an incredible
mother who really had a vision to get
her kids out of the former Soviet Union
so we actually won the lottery and got
out on the last ship in 1989 July of 89
as political asylum refugees and so we
came over to America with the assistance
of a Jewish nonprofit called Nastya and
ended up in Atlanta Georgia because my
dad loved to fishing and so I spent my
entire childhood in Atlanta growing up
ballroom dancing fishing on the
Chattahoochee River playing beach
volleyball like totally idyllic
childhood went to a private school
Atlanta International School where I was
really exposed to a diverse and
international flavor like my best
friends were Danish and French and
spring break was in Val d'Isere and this
was stuff that like I as an immigrant
child couldn't afford but I was exposed
to kids whose parents were international
diplomats and so I started to see that
our world was much bigger than this
little bubble of Russian American
that I grew up in and that totally
shaped me in those formative years and
so I graduated and went to Georgia Tech
found that Georgia Tech was a really
fascinating place started tutoring some
of the athletes there which would be
really helpful in my later work and so
this thread of talking to men started
pretty early on and then after Georgia
Tech the economy crashed it was the
worst time to get a job and my father
left the family he decided to pursue
life with another woman and so I found
myself deeply depressed rug pulled out
from under my feet the job that I had
was on fries and so I bought a one-way
ticket to Vietnam and left ten days
later and I went backpacking alone for
six months around Southeast Asia and it
was the best therapy I could have asked
for like I was orphanage hopping in
Cambodia and when you have a
three-year-old coming towards you with
one leg that's all the therapy you need
because you recognize in that moment
perspective like yeah I don't have a dad
my life feels pretty upside down but I
know I'm gonna be okay because I have
food and shelter and love and family so
I eventually after six months moved to
New York City and my older sister was
rocking it in advertising and she
started taking me out and I had all
these stories and they were like you'd
be really good at this and so my sister
actually helped me get into advertising
and I worked as a digital ad sales
executive for almost seven years and I
loved it it was it was a totally
curiosity led life Bagon relationship
building my last business card read the
Beyonce of digital media so like I did
it big and hard and loved it and that
was my MBA like I learned everything
about business from from doing that and
at the same time I felt really deprived
of cultivating a soul my spirituality
and so I gave myself a goal that I would
save up X amount of dollars and then
after seven years of scrolling away
every Commission check never touched a
single Commission check for seven years
I had enough money to basically leave
and I gave away my stuff and I went
backpacking around the world for 28
months and in those 28 months I decided
to embark on a series of positive
disruptive behaviors because I
recognized that the only way I was going
to come home to myself was to do the
opposite of everything New York had
conditioned me to do so I stopped
wearing makeup I stopped wearing heels I
stopped wearing push-up bras I stopped
leading with sexuality when I met men
and I genuinely led with friendship and
it just changed everything during this
period of time I got to do a lot of
selfish stuff you know like the stuff
that I had been curious about breath
work meditation exploring different
modalities going down to the Amazon
doing ayahuasca in the middle of that
abouthe oh just mind opening stuff and
then I also did a little bit of aid work
I went to a refugee camp in Greece
raised 7,000 dollars and 48 hours went
back to the orphanage that I had worked
out when I was 22 in Cambodia and
painted a mural and I think the most
important thing that happened during
that time was the most important man in
my life died very suddenly of a
pulmonary embolism and I say this
because sometimes our greatest pain
becomes our greatest path if we're lucky
and so when my grandpa died I stopped
backpacking and I flew to LA to take
care of my grandma and be there with my
family and that was nine months of real
painful gut-wrenching grief and
depression and the way that I got out of
it was actually through the support of
my guy friends and so that leads me to
this project that I started in the
throes of losing all masculine sorry
male wisdom in my life you know my dad
had left ten years before then my
grandpa stepped up in his place I didn't
have a boyfriend and I didn't have a
husband so my guy friends really showed
up for me and we would gather around the
campfire and talk about crypto and black
Jain and existentialism and philosophy
and I just thought wow as I travel the
world speaking on stages about hacking
human connection what if I just gathered
my best guy friends in every city made
dinner and we talked about what it means
to be a man and this is pre me to like
nobody's talking about this and I
started doing it and I did the first one
in New York and then two weeks later I
was speaking at tech open air and I
asked for a second slot I said I know
I'm speaking about hacking human
connection but I just started this new
project would you be willing to give me
one more hour and this is why I always
asked she said yes and people waited in
line for two hours after that talk and I
was like whoa where there is curiosity
there's everything like nobody's waited
for two hours after a hacking human
connection talk so it got me realizing
that men were really hungry to have safe
spaces to be heard and to have
conversations about unspoken truths in
intimate settings with a woman who could
create an environment of non-competition
which goes against everything that men
have ever been conditioned to believe to
be true about four strangers in a room
together so I started doing these
dinners around the world and I did them
in Berlin and Tel Aviv and Madrid
Sydney and Melbourne New York SF LA and
I decided this is a book so I transcribe
every dinner and each city is a
different chapter and the the wisdom
that is shared is some of the deepest
and richest conversation I've ever been
privy to because none of the men know
each other and I'm pulling them from all
different parts of my life and so then I
started speaking on stage about my
findings as a woman doing men's work and
then men started coming to me wanting to
work with me one on one and you know I'm
not I'm not a therapist and I'm not an
expert in this because I really believe
that the answers we seek lie and the
questions we're willing to ask and so
I'm a facilitator of asking the
questions that you might be too scared
to ask yourself and and it's just the
most joyful work because the results of
that creates this virtuous cycle of
self-awareness to self-love to
self-expression and that's really my
goal is
to help men love themselves and express
themselves and also the the story of you
pulling the decision out of you to go
and and backpack you did that twice yeah
and that's a very tough decision but it
led to some of your most formative
growth and so those are very beautiful
also the dichotomies between seeing what
was going on in Manhattan for seven
years and ad advertising versus what's
happening in other parts of the world in
a refugee camp so to be able to actually
get into these different worldviews and
like fully immerse oneself in them it
leads to a more holistic perspective and
also to people to potentially even share
that with others and get them more aware
of what actually happens so you use
these words non-competitive environment
for men in these in these dinners also
the word vulnerability is another one I
feel like with some of my strongest
female friends that I could get to
become more vulnerable sometimes than
with my strongest male friends for some
reason so teach us about what this
exactly is this non-competitive vibe
that's there yeah yeah so typically when
men walk into the room together there's
a sense of natural hierarchical
deciphering they're trying to discern
where the power is at right every
relationship is an exchange of power and
so when men walk into a space this is
going back to caveman times they've got
to understand where are they in the
hierarchy and you know according to Jack
Donovan who wrote the way of men man's
ability to thrive depends on small game
the small gang of men that is in his
circle and so we're constantly changing
circles and what I recognize is when we
are in a place of having to prove
ourselves we're not feeling safe and
when we're not feeling safe we're not
being our most sincere version of self
so what I do in
dinner's as I say we're human beings not
human doings nobody's allowed to talk
about their jobs
everybody's on an equal playing field
our phones are on airplane mode because
that way nobody is too important for
somebody else and all of us are giving
the gift of presence which is the
greatest gift that we can give ourselves
or each other and so I think by creating
specific rules and creating a container
of safety that's how we take away that
primal conditioning of I'm walking into
this room and I've got to be the best
and smartest and the richest and the
most powerful it's like no you just got
to be you and bring your powerful
stories to the table of how you became
you and that's all and the beauty is
every single time I do this without fail
we walk in as four strangers and walk
out as friends that have gone through a
once-in-a-lifetime experience
and they always ask to stay in touch you
know we think about women as really
nurturing and community driven men are
seeking that community so much because
they've been deprived of it much of
their lives because of this competitive
breeding and it's very isolating and
loneliness is the greatest epidemic
facing men statistically speaking and
there's a reason for that it's because
of this competition and so when we think
about masculinity modern masculinity
it's so deeply tied to performance and
the reason it's tied to performance is
because when I ask the question what are
the greatest challenges facing men in
uber Zahl over the world I've been doing
this for three years nine times out of
ten the answer is the ability and
pressure to provide is the greatest
challenge because when men don't live up
to their own expectations to their
cultures expectations or to society's
expectations of their performance as
measured in cash they go into a vicious
spiral of shame and it could be really
subtle or really extreme and the way
that men process those feelings of shame
is they anesthetize them because they've
been robbed of the agency to feel their
full spectrum of emotions systematically
by the
Archy and other systems but when they
don't want to feel pain and shame often
what I found is men turned to vices like
alcohol like drugs like fast women like
anything that will detract from the pain
I feel for not being valued in a society
that only values me by the performance
that performance is a metric that is
measured by cash and that goes back to
tribalism right like when we were
cavemen men survived by bringing home
the kill the animal to feed the village
we don't have that but now men survive
by bringing home the cash and that's
their value contribution so what I tell
women is if you want to make your man
feel seen on a level that is euphoric
value him for something other than his
performance and that's a game changer
I love how you tie this into the
biological imperative which is this
hierarchy that has been evolving over
time and how it's taking all the way
historically back to the tribe and
bringing back the kill weren't the feed
people and now that's turned into the
cash
everything's performance-based these
uber rides have become spiritual
practices for me were both massive
question askers relentless curiosity and
so with that constant probing for people
around the world it's been that there's
this pressure 9 out of 10 just replied
you about this pressure the hierarchical
pressures and so to be seen fully as not
just for providing cash and the
pressures there are four that what else
has opened up for the in the
conversations because it makes so much
sense that there's the that you come in
you're not talking about work so there's
no hierarchy turns into that header our
key your trust talking to each other
about your families my friends about
challenges you had yeah teach us about
yeah yeah so I just had a men's dinner a
few days ago here in SF and I gathered
all fathers and it was the first
father's only dinner and it was super
fascinating because it was from 32 all
the way to 63 year old fathers who had
kids at different ages and I just let
them talk about the moment when did you
feel connected to your child how many
men were there were five five and then
average sizes usually reflect this yeah
I've experimented as big as eight and
I've gotten it down to four because I
want to give each men the space to use
his voice and if there's one dominating
personality it gets really complicated
and so facilitating four feels good and
is it one it's turn based so it's
everyone's in one conversation
everyone's in one conversation yeah we
don't split off into it's Jeffersonian
but it's also deeply interactive
I welcome contrarian opinions and we
just all have to be loving and
encouraging of each other and you kind
of walk through maybe as the facilitator
of certain topics that you think would
and then you ask them a question and
then they kind of go in is that yeah so
I have I have a prep email that before
you step in this is my mission this is
what I'm creating in the world we get to
be visiting professors in each other's
lives this conversation will be
transcribed anonymized and a chapter in
the book only share what you feel would
add value to the generation reading this
because a hundred years from now when
people ask who were the men of 2019 I
want to elevate the voices of men of
high integrity and I consider you to be
one of them and so really it's it's my
love letter to men because as a woman
who has seen the entire spectrum of
interactions with men from super
Integris to deeply lacking I decided I
wanted to rewrite my own narrative of
how I saw men and in doing so I'm
helping rewrite hopefully the narrative
of much of the world because in this
post me to culture we have a lot of
shaming and blaming of men and that is
justified and at the same time there
needs to be a counterbalance elevating
the voices of men of high integrity
elevating the everyday heroes is my
greatest contribution that I can do to
equalize this balance okay yes now take
us to this is cool because the guys are
32 as dads or 64 is dad so their kids
are kind of all over the age range and
yeah so this must be an interesting
conversation between them yeah yeah so
what was really interesting was all of
them agreed that their moment of really
getting fatherhood and feeling connected
as dads didn't happen when their wives
got pregnant didn't happen when the
babies were born happened when it was
the cusp of toddlerhood happened when
the child could laugh and interact and
had personality and a response like a
feedback loop and there
a little bit I think of shame in that
because they wanted to feel connected to
their kid but again what's so beautiful
about these dinners is this is
illuminating the unspoken truths the
stuff that they haven't even wanted to
admit to themselves and I think it's
something that a lot of dads can relate
to and it also creates this divisive
divide with the moms because at the same
time you know so many of my best friends
just gave birth
they've lost their identity so there's
this massive power shift of women become
utilitarian and fully disengaged with
their sexual beings because they've got
a eight-pound child that is 100%
dependent on them men feel like they're
losing their wife losing the identity of
what that woman was to them to this tiny
being that they can't even connect to or
derived joy from so now men have lost
their place in their own home and and it
takes a really open aware communicative
couple to make it through that journey
and so we talked a lot about that you
you're describing the dynamic in a very
fresh way for for me and it's more
really interesting thinking about it
when when when it's this selfishness
self less selflessness that starts
kicking in of having to give a hundred
percent of oneself to to the child and
then how that affects the dynamic
between the couple and then I really
appreciated that moment of awareness for
the father of when there's a feedback
loop that's enabled between the child
and themselves and then the personality
starts emerging and it's like how do I
and fatherhood is is one of the greatest
rites of passage that we have as men and
as motherhood is for women and so there
was this really great TED talk about how
across the board fatherhood has
prevented more violence across gang
communities than any other single factor
because when a man recognizes that he
has a mission that is bigger than
himself he goes into warrior protector
mode and so fatherhood is the antidote
to violence there's something that
happens to men when they recognize that
there is a legacy a living legacy
happening inside of their own home that
they up level as men and it changes the
way that they treat their women there is
this newfound respect like she's the
mother of my child that phrase kept
coming up in the conversation on Monday
night and it just was beautiful and so I
really want to do more of these fathers
dinners because I think men are so
fearful of what comes with fatherhood
the losing of the wife the losing of the
identity but what is gained with
fatherhood is a spiritual experience
that definitely needs to be celebrated
yeah there's a totally this transcendent
feeling that comes with something that
is a lineage of you and of that you have
to prioritize that over the hierarchical
dynamics of workplace environments but
at the same time figuring out how to
balance that in to become a better
provider as well give the child the best
sort of tools and resources they need so
is there it has that also been something
that's that's reoccurring is that is
what's - difficulty have passed that
point of like okay well then you maybe
get into the adolescent years how you
deal with kids in the hata lesson years
how you figure out some of the maybe
challenges that arise throughout these
processes yeah so what I found really
interesting was the way that modern men
parent is in response to the way that
they were parented so when we talk about
breaking the generational wounding and
that cycle only persists if we're
unaware of the ways in which our parents
knowingly and unknowingly traumatized us
because nobody's parents are going to
come off scot-free right we all
experience parts of our parents that are
a projection of the
that their parents did so really what
was so beautiful about this men's dinner
was each of the guys came forward and
explained you know my dad came from Iran
and this was normative in growing up and
I will never lay a finger on my child I
was like yes that's what we need we need
men taking a stand to be better humans
to their children and that's what I'm
seeing and why I'm so optimistic about
the future is conscious parenting is now
becoming a normative topic and I think
it's it's really the most powerful way
forward to transform our entire society
not to pass down the generational trauma
but to decouple it so I have this guided
visual story that I do on stage where I
say we're all individual nesting dolls
and so from 0 to 10 weeks you're this
tiny amorphous blob of cells no gender
is assigned to you you're the tiniest
wooden doll at 10 weeks you get your
first nesting doll and that's anatomical
conditioning so hormones start racing
through your body testosterone making
your penis estrogen making the
beginnings of your vulva and then at
nine months when you're born that's the
second nesting doll and that's your
familial conditioning so how did your
family treat your gender will depend on
how their families treated their gender
the next nesting doll is your cultural
conditioning so that's what kind of
culture were you raised in were you
raised in a culture where there was a
lot of misogyny a lot of machoism was it
an immigrant culture was it Latino black
all of those nuances make a huge
difference the next nesting doll is
societal and that societal conditioning
deeply thinks about patriarchal systems
deeply thinks about you know societies
like China and India where the value of
a woman's gender is not high and then
the last nesting doll is your own
ideology and that is a conglomeration of
all of the experiences that you have had
with the opposite sex including and not
limited to sexual trauma
great joys ex-boyfriends ex-girlfriends
and attachment theory prevailing the
relationship that you've had with your
opposite sex parent so that's one person
that's one nesting doll and when you
walk down the street we're all nesting
dolls and so the only way that I see
forward is to decouple all of the
nesting dolls one layer at a time and
create a level of self-awareness that
writes a truer narrative than the one
that you have been swimming in your
whole life
so that's where you got to get curious
and question everything you've ever
known to be true if the nesting dolls is
a really good way to adjust in when we
whenever we talk to especially a
neuroscientist as a psychologist
psychiatrist just especially ones that
are studying the for early formative
years and even like time in the womb
like there's a lot of formation the dogs
that are net these nested times so that
it's a peep to be able to know how to to
peel those away like dissect into them
you take this old code that can
sometimes be so traumatic or all these
issues and it's sort of you know write
yourself some code updates that can
maybe make yourself feel like the divine
being that that we are and that that's
that's this makes sense that it's
facilitated by these small intimate
settings where there's a high degree of
vulnerability the hierarchy is not being
prioritized where phones are to offer on
air moment I'm trying to create a
positively disruptive experience
so anything that is disruptive to the
norm and positively adds to your life is
what I'm all about
yeah yeah I'm likewise disruptive to the
norm and positively I'd say your life
it's so critical there's a lot of this
sort of path that's already been being
walked down by the old code is making
the path really easily accessible for
for most people to file into but the new
code these new paths the paths toward
spiritual divinity towards unity towards
global cohesion with Pachamama with more
mother earth talking about raising
children and the differences that we
feel when we raise them around around
the world and these things are the ones
that I think by doing the salons that
you're doing are catalyzing the most
some of the most pressing conversations
that that we need to have I love
learning about this from you and it
feels as though that I have so many more
questions like what is the difference
between doing one with father's doing
one with like 25 to 30 year old mentor
yeah that aren't fathers yet and yeah
yeah I've never just done young guys so
I try to have great age difference
interesting yeah and I try to have a
member of the queer community
represented in every dinner there wasn't
a member of the queer community
represented in this father's dinner and
that was a shame because I think the
more diverse my my group the deeper
breadth and depth of insights shared so
yeah yeah okay so everything from age
from age to sexual orientation to
ethnicity I've had I've had some some
tough conversations about race and and I
also have learned as a facilitator that
you've got to create a safe space first
above all and what's really cool is when
you do that you know there were some
questions that the straight men had
towards the the bisexual and gay men in
the dinners and this
and every single time because how often
do straight men get to ask questions and
so a big part of my dinner is in the
prep work I send the seven questions
that I universally ask all over the
world and those are my control variable
questions what does it mean to be a man
today what are the greatest challenges
facing men what parts of masculinity do
you celebrate what parts of masculinity
feel archaic at best and devastating at
worst is gender a social construct these
are questions that are meant to get our
minds marinating so that when they walk
in they know exactly where we're going
and we go deep that's great it's a great
marination thank you thank you and then
I save the spot for their question and I
say you have a unique opportunity to ask
any question that comes to mind and what
I find is the wisdom comes from the
questions the men ask because the
answers we seek lie and the questions
were brave enough to ask a lot and so
one of one of the best questions I've
ever had asked in my dinners and this is
a core part of my research one of my Chi
friends said have any of you ever felt
like less of a man in the presence of
another man and this was one of the
earlier dinners that I did and that
question just illuminated so much about
what is unspoken about men and when
people ask me what are you learning
about men I think I'm learning how
deeply similar we are my overarching
thesis is yes we are biologically
different we have different hormones but
we are cosmically the same and we share
the same heart we share the same
insecurities we share the same pain
points around value we share the same
heart over objectification you know it
changes what we get objectified over
women beauty of body men in sweeping
generalizations ability to provide in
finance but we are so much more similar
than we are different and when I read
books to supplement my primary search
primary research like king warrior
magician lover which is a cult classic
in masculine
studies I see myself in every single one
of these archetypes and so it's
fascinating to me that we have books
that are seen through the lens of oh
this is the four archetypes for men by
men and I'm like wait a second I've been
a king I've been a warrior I've been a
magician and I've been a lover and I'm a
woman so it brings me back to my thesis
that we are bodies of water walking in
skins and I happen to be in the skin of
a woman and you happen to be in the skin
of a man and because of that
conditioning and nesting dolls the world
has created narratives for us but if we
go back and back and back and back to
pre ten weeks to inception we were
genderless beings and so I challenge
people to be genderless I challenge
people to not use their gender to excuse
or promote anything just to be human
and I've challenged myself I used to say
I'm a woman doing men's work I don't say
that anymore I'm just a human novel
raava cotton one of my guy friends said
this on a podcast he said I try to strip
away every identity yeah and it was I
thought about that and I was like our
identities are really convenient
narratives yeah you know it's it's a
convenient narrative that we get to use
to play the immigrant card to play the
woman card I don't want to do that game
anymore you're friends with Navarro
Vikash yeah he was Ronnie we had we had
some really deep conversations around
the kitchen for a week and and those are
some of the conversations I'll remember
for the rest of my life oh my goodness
okay because I worked with him a few
years ago stripping away of identities
is also something that is so critical as
to how culture will just ident
identity identity identity identity ills
it's always trying to like label
something to make like reduce it to
something that's easier to understand
are you a liberal are you conservative
that's like the most most popular one a
man or a woman are you a which religion
do you subscribe to I mean it's like
it's like subscriptions to all these
different services but like really when
you look at what happens inside of the
womb when the first cells are starting
to form I mean these are divine human
cells and that the viewing it that way
really inspires that unity that would
that we are these water bodies and that
with this this earth suit skin that
there's it's a lot of spirituality that
we should dive into in a little bit
I have an interesting question asked
because this is probably on on behalf of
some of the higher the hierarchical side
of the of the conversation
one could potentially say that the the
amount of influence that one has over
the trajectory of civilization is could
that but it could potentially be their
place on a hierarchy Wow and so when
someone that's kind of just like
chilling in like a 10,000 person City in
the middle of Nebraska is kind of like
doesn't really have as much of a say
over society as one of the heads of the
the companies that control two billion
human perception every single day across
their internet companies so how do you
how do you have that coincide and
balanced into the the conversations that
you have around these topics yeah it's a
really great point and when I'm curating
these dinners sometimes the men that
attend are deeply powerful and I mixed
them with men that are deeply creative
or everyday humans and the way that I
balance it is by putting them in the
same room together so that they
understand that they are actually
experiencing life through the same lens
and their desire is the only thing that
changes it one has the desire to impact
an influence on a million scale and one
has the desire to impact an influence
within his community but it's it's just
an understanding of what community are
you associating with you could associate
with your village or you could associate
with your world and so that's that's the
only difference they're equally valuable
just their amount of power that they
desire is what changes how big or small
their community that they get to
influence is ok let's let's let's stay
on that a little longer just the
different colors on a color wheel is
another way to put it right maybe the
like we can use hair colors here purple
maybe this you know million
it's a scale thing and then maybe red is
just village I mean it influence trade
over the trajectory of only five people
in your community or maybe millions or
billions in the world a civilization
that's running in its state of just
perpetual day-to-day economic growth is
it really you use the word kind of like
these are equal right colors on the
color wheel red and purple in the sense
but in this in the sense purple coming
up with an innovation in code that gets
to billions of people can make it so
that you could maybe tackle one of the
challenges that could be an existential
risk to the whole entire plan in the
first place so can is there than a one
of these colors is potentially more so
it goes back to unleashing that genius
that you're born with and you can only
create as much impact in the world as
you are aware of and you are able to
believe in yourself to be a potential
solution to that problem so you can't
artificially force someone who's in the
red who believes that the highest
version of himself is being a great dad
in his village because that's that's as
big as he sees himself that's as much
contribution as he sees and that devoted
father is changing the next generation
for his kids that guy would lose himself
in the purple color because he wouldn't
be able to step up and believe in
himself to a place where he's dealing
with global problem solving and if a man
is attacking a problem that he doesn't
feel or woman that he doesn't feel he
genuinely can add value to it's a lost
cause so I think we need both we we are
all solving problems in the world
and as long as we're solving problems
there's trillions of problems to be
solved we need everybody to be all hands
on deck but only where they feel their
highest contribution
we can't force contribution so then
let's let's let's move into how when you
when you pair together someone that may
be you know in the in the millions of
the color purple of like a tab of
influencing the trajectory of people's
lives versus someone that is just you
know maybe influencing a couple people's
lives their families lives
that's everything and then you remove
all of that you remove the economic
influences that these people have and
you and the phones are on there promote
they're talking is what what is the
dynamic that's kind of created from
their experience do you ever hear of how
they kind of find the magic in the
mundane yeah when they talk about their
love when they talk about women when
they talk or their partners when they
talk about their kids there is a deep
appreciation of the simple pleasures in
life regardless of how big the scale of
problems you're trying to tackle there
is that solidarity over what matters and
what matters at the end of the day is a
man coming home to a place where he
feels valued and loved and appreciated
where he feels like he can take off the
suit that he's been tackling problems
with all day and just be and and those
men always find commonalities around the
just being not doing because this is
something as a writer I'm really
frustrated about we have the most
nuanced topic or at least one of them
gender and as a writer I only have two
words to explain it masculine and
feminine but because of the way that
these words have been misused the brain
instantly conflates feminine with female
and masculine with male and no matter
how accurate I'm trying to explain
something I know that there
always a risk that my audience won't
hear it not because they're not smart or
they want to but because they've been
conditioned so what I'm challenging
myself to do is positive disruptive
vernacular I've been really trying to
stop using feminine and masculine and
just only go with what I feel is the two
states of being of all humans
universally we are in a state of being
where we feel or we are in a state of
doing where we create yeah yeah and it
is nor feminine or masculine can within
this being and doing it seems as though
when you're maybe more so in a village
that you're maybe in a state of being or
often when you're in a Silicon Valley
you're in a place of doing more often
and it seems to be quite out of balance
you potentially maybe even both of those
locations but this is what one of the
one of the great questions is why are we
not in a perpetual state of just being
along the rock why do we need to be in a
state of constantly doing on the rock
well because the economy needs to grow
and there need to be so many problems to
be tackled and we need to electrify and
connect everything via the internet of
things and get to Mars and the moon and
so how do you how do you live with that
narrative of the singularity with the
narrative of just be I lean toward the
just be I really think that if we could
sit in the stillness of the cave of our
own minds if we could live in a state of
meditative gratitude universally the
world would be a kamar more joyful a
less violent place because if you can
connect to yourself first and foremost
you can then connect to your fellow
human and that trickles down from the
highest of leadership all the way down
to the smallest nuclear family unit
I think that it's no surprise that SF
and a few of these big metropolitan
cities are having the highest upticks in
adoption of meditation and Eastern
philosophies you know when Esalen
started in 1962 and they brought Eastern
practice to the West they were really
not seen as scholarly or academic or
they weren't validated for their vision
and it wasn't until Alan Watts came and
taught and study there and Maslow wrote
the hierarchy of needs that people
started recognizing the importance of
world philosophies being woven into the
tapestry of American thought leader and
so now we know that the president
meditates we know that the greatest
leaders in the world Ray Dalio meditates
20 minutes every morning and every
afternoon Tim Ferriss like the names go
on and and it's it's so important now
more than ever to create the being state
in micro moments every day because just
the practice of gratitude neurologically
rewires the brain so I'm a really big
proponent I think the doing is is always
going to be there the being is the
personal quest to enjoy the doing yeah
that's good stuff yeah well thank you
for voting that out of me yeah this is
what we do we help the shiny the shiny
so I love that okay so we practice the
state of the being to to make it so that
the journey of what we do with the doing
it's just extremely transcendent and
fulfilling beyond words yeah
the doing is the manifestation of
emotional desire meets action you see
something you desire it you have a
vision for creating it and then when you
execute it when you give birth to it
there is a feeling of pride that you are
able to do so there is a feeling of
contribution that what you have created
is generative for your community for
your society for humanity that's why the
doing matters but until you get to a
place of sincere being anything that you
try to do is feeding from the pains and
the voids of unworked through past pain
so the being is the process of sitting
still with the beasts of the mind and
allowing yourself to see pain as your
greatest professor I would not be on
this quest for masculinity if my dad
wasn't my best friend and left when I
was 21 and my grandpa died two years ago
I think our greatest pain births our
greatest purpose yeah and we're all in
pain so just find a way to transmute
that and you're gonna be on a path
that's much more rewarding than sitting
solely in the pain I can sit with the
pain and I can see it as that college
professor that just wouldn't let me off
the hook but that college professor
taught me more than any other class did
yeah I like that pain is one of the
greatest professors on the other side of
the greatest traumas and amid walls of
adversity our greatest treasures mhm yes
I like those a lot and okay I want I
want to see some of your thoughts about
this because this is uh this is kind of
what we're what we're heading to as much
as being is such a critical thing to
embody like you said the metropolis of
the world are embodying these Eastern
spiritual practices of meditation and
the beautiful transcendent experiences
of unity and ego death and whatnot that
we can experience from that oneness
while we are also somehow in these
metropolis is building the artificial
intelligence agents were building the
virtual realities we're building the
synthetic biology x' and neuro
technologies were building the
connecting of to that singularity that
we're heading to so so what what do you
what do you how do you coincide again
this that we're moving into the dis
crazy exponential technology age with
the with the being I think we're running
away from ourselves in certain ways
we're not living in the present we're
building the future that's my first
reaction my second is there's something
that is deeply unfulfilled about the
modern that is creating a sensationalism
of futurism interesting and so if you're
not satisfied with where you're at if
you're not satisfied with where
humanities at you're pouring all of your
resources into architecting in the
future and my only my only thought on
that is is is this an equitable place
where both men and women are coming
together to create the future because
from my understanding it's not and when
I asked at Davos I was asking a panelist
who was speaking about AI it's like so
if you imagine that AI has a gender what
would it be and he laughed I mean he's
like it's a man obviously it's built by
men and that just made my heart sink
because I was like this thing that is
happening that is irrefutable e
happening AI is being built by 90
percent men with very little female
perspective so we have one homogeneous
opinion architecting the future and that
is terrifying because that undoes all of
the work that i'm personally on a
mission to do which is build bridges
joining the genders and so we've got to
be really careful about how we build the
future inclusive of not just gender but
diversity and gender isn't man versus
woman you know
the the jerseys that are coming up when
they hear us say the word gay that's so
outdated
the N archaic because they consider
themselves fluid they're not thinking am
i gay am i straight they're thinking I
am a human being and who I love is not
dependent on their genitalia and that's
the kind of progressive thinking that we
really need to get on board with and
give equal opportunity to every
different socio-economic background who
wants to unleash their genius because
otherwise we're going to have AI built
by white men and that's the direction
that's going in and that's pretty
terrifying
okay so when when when we look at when
we look at what's happening in the
existing state of code that we're in
right now it in so many ways has evolved
with so many hiccups and errors in some
of the code that we're like we can't fix
this there's too much stuff going on the
complexity we're just gonna focus on
building the new code we're gonna
architect the new stuff and we're gonna
do doo doo doo doo all the time doo doo
doo doo doo so that we can obsolete the
old problems within when 9 out of 10 if
that's the case or that are building the
artificial intelligence agents that it
will eventually become the ones that
create the super intelligences that are
white men that the bridge is that you're
building did all the all the things that
you listed about these Millennials in
the Generation Z and even the generation
that comes after the Generation Z the we
don't really fully comprehend the what
evolution is is on its path of doing to
the brain and the heart and the humans
on the rock it's it's very difficult to
be able to see something like a fluidity
in the way that people treat themselves
as just human and who they love and also
of the way that whatever it means to
have tendencies to want to be no
actually I don't want to do
social-emotional
I just want to learn how to compute like
that's all someone else do that that
these are just these are these are what
are you know they're different they're
idiosyncratic just differences and that
we to be able to treat it that way as
something that we're still trying to
comprehend as part of evolution could be
better for us how do you how do you
reconcile how do you actually change you
know you're doing that right now with
what you're doing with the narrative of
the the men's dinners and as well as
these and the salon to be able to make
the bridges is that is that the the what
are the best strategies that we have for
for being able to make the updated code
towards that yeah I think it's for every
male futurist that is an AI look at your
circle of friends and pull up a person
of a different background race and
gender with you mentor them if I was
smart enough to go into AI I would but
I'm doing this from the storytelling
perspective where I feel I can tap into
my unique gifts so if you're a female
scientist and you don't feel like you
have access to the same opportunities if
you're coming from a different race
ethnicity socio-economic class fight to
be part of the future and if you're
already there and you're sitting
comfortably and you're privileged as a
man as a white man then look at the
ownness that you have to create not a
homogenized version of the future but an
accurate one and and that's where the
personal accountability comes in and so
I ask all of us to see each other as
brothers and sisters in the other how
would you treat your sister who was up
and coming how would you treat your
cousin from a different family that's
what the global family is waiting for is
for us to just drop our excuses drop the
pain points and say we're here at the
most critical time in history enough
with the ego enough with the identities
and and the war between the genders the
only war that we're gonna be fighting is
within ourselves if we don't get our
[ __ ] together and and coalesce and join
forces on activating all of our
collective genius there are so I was in
crypto and blockchain for years and I
did it as a hobby and I started this
Facebook group called love coin 3000
people joined and suddenly I felt a
responsibility to help other women get
into this field because I would go to
conferences like Davos and I would see
stage after stage six men on a panel and
I was like you've got to be [ __ ]
kidding me because I know personally at
least fifteen brilliant women that could
knock your pants off right now but none
of them are given opportunities and so
enough with that like if you're a man on
a six-man panel get off the panel
because when you're on that panel
everyone looking is realizing that you
are feeding into the archaic notions of
the past instead of being a champion of
the progress needed to shape the future
yeah you had a really great action point
there is you know we are who we surround
ourselves with too so to be able to to
do things like uplift those in the lower
socioeconomic statuses or to to take in
people into our social circles that are
of different
places of the world than we are these
are very very important things to do
yeah we yeah we just we just finished up
yeah some of the interviews in Cambridge
where that was happening and it was like
really awakening and it was like fine
like this is what happens when you take
the time to immerse yourself into what
it's like growing up in a different part
of the world yeah yeah and it's
something as simple as like open your
couch to couch surfing allow immigrants
to sleep on your couch allow go out to
dinner with people that aren't in your
social sphere you know we kind of float
in this very privileged 1% intellectual
elite and so even my dinner salons are a
reflection of that as much as I try to
pull men in from different backgrounds
they're aware and thinking that is a
privilege Maslow's hierarchy of needs
doesn't give you that when you're in a
refugee camp just trying to stay alive
so so to those that have privilege and I
consider privilege anything beyond
survival we are all deeply privileged
its intersectional privilege that's
really up at the core of it we have a
responsibility and acting upon that
responsibility is the highest honor that
you can pay forward for the privilege
that you have so it's almost like an IOU
it's like hey I won the lottery I got to
leave the Soviet Union and become a
business woman in America I got to be
born to a mother who at 26 years old
spearheaded our exit from a country that
wasn't gonna let me actualize my highest
potential I was so deeply loved and
nurtured and it didn't matter how little
money we had in America we had all the
opportunities and so if we're living in
a place like America or any country in
the world for that matter and you are
fed happy and loved just get curious
about what you can do today to be a
steward for positive evolution and
that's where talking to strangers has
become a spiritual practice because what
we're not live
in this world of extremes where it's
like I either am a martyr and become
Mother Teresa or nothing it's like there
are micro moments of humanity in your
over with your Starbucks barista even in
your leadership style like pull aside
the intern one of the greatest bosses I
ever had pulled my desk into his suite
the president of this company ignition
Mikey hurts them love that man till the
day I die
he saw me as a 19 year old precocious
kid he believed in me and he treated me
as his right-hand man and because of
that I felt capable of things that
people twice my age weren't doing and I
was 19 years old traveling the world for
clean water to Africa on a 65 day world
relay and I got to experience some of
the highest highs of my career at 19
because there was somebody who opened
the door and believed in me and gave me
a responsibility to run with that is how
we change the system yeah yeah very well
said and synthesized this is this has
been so such a powerful episode and
conversation I want to ask you a couple
questions on the way out I love that you
said synthesize always on that synthesis
you know positive feedback loop yeah
yeah what can we do to help with basic
physiological needs across a lot of full
actualization the new codes the first
question is are we alone in the cosmos
to think that we are alone in the cosmos
is is to be deeply unaware of our
smallness and insignificance we are but
one trillionth of all the possibilities
that live within the cosmos so we are
very much in good company company that
we may never see or feel but we are
definitely not alone in my personal
opinion and there's something deeply
comforting about that next question is
are we in a simulation I believe we're
in a created simulation on a macro and
micro level the simulation exists within
us because we are living out a
simulation that we actively through our
wounding and through our desire these
two polarities push us and pull us into
actions those actions create memories
those memories create character that's
our internal simulation we then feed
into the collective simulation and play
roles in each other's lives and then
there's beyond the collective there's
the ephemeral there's the astral plane
simulation so I think that yeah it's a
nesting doll of simulations and our last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
mmm love
love I think the conversation about a
Father's love was deeply touching this
week and that feels top of mind I think
love is the most illogical and powerful
force on earth I think the entire point
of life is love we do nothing meaningful
without love so love is is the most
beautiful thing we could ever be a part
of or hope to create we love you very
much
such a great yeah I'm so grateful
likewise likewise extremely grateful for
you extremely grateful for Ron thank you
so much for producing and directing Ron
we love you very much also I want to say
that when brave new men actually ends up
coming out we can have you back we can
actually we can unpack the stories the
anonymized stories yes in there and we
can unpack those in greater detail there
will be a lot of fun Wow so let's do
that for another part part two you shout
out to everyone else for watching and
tuning in we greatly appreciate you we
would love love love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know also check out the links below to V
cos work brave new men calm also
released an Instagram week's card below
go and check those out have more
conversations to your friends your
family or coworkers online on social
media about the topics that we talked
about in the show go and chat more about
it share these conversations more and
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations around the world that
you believe in maybe create your own
men's salons create your own dinners
around these conversations support Vika
or links are below support simulation
our links are below and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world update the old coats to
the new codes we love you very much
thanks for tuning in and we'll see you
soon
peace
[Music]
[Music]